quasiment j moins 400 avant le début des
Jeux olympiques de Paris 2024 les
Yvelines seront sur le devant de la
scène avec de nombreuses épreuves
accueillies pour les JO rien qu'à 50 ans
Yvelines on dit nombre 4 sites
olympiques collines d'Élancourt
Vélodrome National Stadium de BMX ou
encore le Golf National où se tient
samedi vous le voyez la journée
olympique c'est de 10h à 20h l'entrée
est gratuite et Chloé Pereira est avec
nous en plateau chargé de projet de
l'événement pour parler de cette journée
olympique rendez-vous fort de
l'agglomération on a l'habitude à TV 78
de le couvrir d'habitude c'est ouvert
uniquement au aux élèves de
l'agglomération de 50 ans en Yvelines là
cette fois-ci c'est une journée ouverte
à tous pourquoi faire ce choix à un peu
plus d'un an désormais des des Jeux
Olympiques alors chaque année on fait
des petites nouveautés aussi pour voilà
renouveler aussi nous notre programme
d'activité et c'est vrai que cette année
ça nous semblait important de de convier
les familles 50 chinoises les les
adultes comme les plus jeunes
à venir se réunir dans ce site ce futur
site olympique qui est le Golf National
pour découvrir
tous en fait tous les âges découvrir de
nouvelles pratiques on a on a pas mal de
pratiques assez inédites on a de
l'escalade on aura du BMX du football
américain aussi parce que ce serait pas
que des pratiques olympiques il y aura
vraiment une journée dédiée au sport
finalement exactement avec aussi un
village Sky pour mettre en âme aussi les
toutes les directions un peu de
l'agglomération et aussi d'autres
activités comme la visite du Golf
National
la possibilité aussi de faire un footing
de 5 km dans le golf pour tenter de
gagner du coup des deux sœurs pour le 10
km du marathon pour tous
plein d'activités et d'ailleurs donc je
disais on parle d'une journée olympique
il y a bien deux journées olympiques
puisque la veille le 23 il y aura une
journée dédiée au scolaire finalement
une journée d'hélioscolaire une journée
ouverte à tous le samedi au Golf
National ouais c'est ça bah pour la
troisième du coup années consécutive on
fait une journée dédiée au scolaire du
territoire là on va accueillir 24
classes de 6e et CM2 sur toute la
journée donc c'est une journée qui
commence à 9h30 qui se termine vers
16h15 avec du coup quatre ateliers par
classe dans la journée donc un atelier
handisport et on essaye aussi de comment
dire de mettre toutes les classes aussi
sur des ateliers vélo voilà et du coup
l'objectif c'est de faire grimper
tranquillement cet engouement je le
disais on a 400 jours quasiment là de
l'échéance olympique
aussi
on va dire on veut que tout le monde
soit pris par cette ce cette atmosphère
des jeux on veut que tout le monde se
sente concerné et donc c'est pour nous
important justement de d'ouvrir cet
événement au plus grand nombre ça
suscite de l'engouement chez vous ça
pourrait peut-être vous inspirer pour de
futurs créations Cécile Palou une
pression thérape autour des Jeux
Olympiques je sais pas moi je mets ça je
l'ai vu sur la table je sais pas vous
inspire les Jeux Olympiques qui arrivent
bientôt
ça va être un bon moment de communion
moi je trouve ça trop beau que tout le
monde se réunisse autour du sport et
enfin ouais je pense c'est beau quoi moi
j'aime bien ce principe
oui monsieur je partage cet avis et
c'est une idée de partage donc quoi
qu'il arrive c'est chouette de réunir
les gens peu importe la passion
finalement un peu le programme vous avez
commencé à en parler alors on pourra
tester une trentaine de sport olympique
ou pas olympique vous avez parlé de
l'escalade par exemple quels sont les
sports qu'on pourra tester il y aura du
hockey sur gazon du baseball du tennis
de table du tir sportif du handball on a
de la gymnastique de la GR
du vélo voilà il y en a vraiment pour
tous les goûts et vraiment voilà encore
une fois adapté à tous donc des
démonstrations aussi au programme des
démonstrations du coup on a un programme
de démonstration sur scène et sur les
ateliers toute la journée donc des
démonstrations de BMX flat de breakdance
de cheerleading
on a aussi sur les ateliers des
démonstrations du tir à l'arc et de
gymnastique et donc les ingrédients
aussi de cette journée c'est de faire
venir des sportifs est-ce que vous
pouvez nous révéler en avant-première
quelques sportifs qui sont présents ou
justement jusqu'au dernier moment ils
laissent planer le doute sur leur
présence son imagine ils ont un agenda
très chargé c'est sportifs
mais alors il y a beaucoup de sportifs
du territoire issu des associations
on a des on a Kevin Meyer aussi qui est
très fort en BMX flat donc un
professionnel de la pratique on a un
groupe du coup de break professionnel du
territoire aussi et voilà de sportifs on
avait parlé cette journée elle est
montée elle est organisée avec les
associations du territoire qui sont
partenaire c'est important pour nous de
mettre en avant aussi le tissu
simplement le tissu associatif 5
continents et beaucoup d'associations
ont répondu présentes donc c'est ce qui
va faire de cette journée une journée
formidable
athlétisme mais aussi le Kevin Meyer du
BMX flat
il y a aussi des choses à gagner alors
vous le disiez on pourra gagner
notamment son dossard pour la course du
10 km alors ce qu'il faut savoir ce
qu'il y aura un marathon pour tous
Peut-être que vous savez déjà si vous ne
regardez mais il y aura un marathon pour
tous pour pour ces JO on pourra gagner
son dossard lors de cet événement vous
le disiez en courant 5 km voilà alors en
fait lors de cet événement nous on a un
lieu où les personnes pourront venir
s'inscrire
pour en fait participer au 5 km de un
footing en fait dans le Golf National et
suite à ça ils pourront tenter de gagner
de ça pour le 10 km du marathon pour
tous voilà c'est ça à faire minimum pour
se qualifier justement qu'on veut encore
une fois ouvrir à tous et donc tous les
partisans ont l'opportunité en tout cas
de tenter leur chance pour gagner ce
c'est de ça
sur le départ de ce marathon pour tout
ça alors ils sont pas tous à gagner lors
de la journée olympique mais en tout cas
c'est le nombre de places ouvertes au
départ des places aussi pour aller voir
directement les JO
pas gagné
à faire gagner pour pour les JO pareil
sous forme de tirage au sort sur le sur
ce sur le samedi les personnes toutes
les personnes pourront tenter de venir
s'inscrire un endroit aussi dédié dans
notre village et donc le tirage au sort
sera fait après l'événement de
représenter le Programme des bénévoles
de 50 ans en Yvelines pendant ces JO où
est-ce qu'on en est concrètement dans ce
programme alors là pour l'instant on est
en fait on veut tout lancer ce samedi
donc il faut venir faut voir le
lancement de toutes ces actions donc ce
programme en fait on souhaiterait voilà
encore une fois
recruter un grand nombre de bénévoles
pour aider Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines
dans les différentes missions liées à
l'accueil des jeux donc
des bénévoles vraiment dédiés au
territoire 50 en Yvelines exactement sur
des missions assez similaires d'accueil
d'orientation du coup mais là autour des
sites olympiques
et donc il y aura aussi le site officiel
des JO à 50 ans de nuit qui sera lancée
donc grande journée de lancement autour
de cette journée olympique une question
plus pratique pour terminer on l'a dit
c'est gratuit et ce qu'il faut
s'inscrire au préalable on peut venir
directement sur place samedi alors c'est
entrée totalement libre entre 10h et 20h
totalement gratuit sans inscription vous
pouvez venir même manger sur place on
aura des foutres voilà tout pour pour
rendre heureux tout le monde et le
rendez-vous à vous le voyez de 10 heures
à 20h au Golf National de 50 ans en
Yvelines pour cette journée olympique
cette fois-ci donc première édition
ouverte à tous c'est pas la première
édition dans l'absolu mais c'est la
première édition qui est ouverte à tous
merci beaucoup Chloé Pereira d'être venu
en parler en plateau